let's go to our old friend Dante from
Florida who I now I am convinced Dante
I'm gonna have it right today you are a
Bernie supporter but you like Tulsi but
you were never a Tulsi voter you were
always a Bernie voter do I have it right
now yes very good
what's up Dante all right so um I wanted
to kind of push back on this media
explanation for why happen in Iowa and
that and a lot of people in progressive
independent media been saying this to
that more likely than anything it's just
record breaking there are locking in
confidence that let the whole debacle in
Iowa and for me that requires you to
have the assumption that the people at
the DNC
in charge of the Democratic Party are
operating in good faith and oh dear
Dante your connections loaf I what what
you we lost about half of what you said
there
you would did so I I think I know where
you're getting at what would appear to
convince you that this was incompetence
and not a conspiracy like what what
would you need to see there is nothing
that that couldn't convince me that this
is incompetence because we do know we
are not people who running the NCR and
they're not good for that do you have
shown time and time again that they're
willing to do all types of unethical
tricks the undermine suppresses in
primaries to support the establishment
candidates so just off the bat alone
they they aren't good feedback let's
take it step by step Dante because
you're shot out of a cannon today which
I can appreciate let me ask you this
let's imagine that the Iowa caucuses
were a completely fake fraudulent
concocted thing by the DNC all they got
out of it was one extra delegate for
Pete and never in the history of the
Democratic primary has it come down to
one delegate so was it worth it because
in the end it's not really gonna do
anything for them
the delegates aren't the the main point
of Iowa I think the amount of Delegates
that they have um in the Democratic
convention fun set so it's not when I
would gives you a huge lead in delegates
it's the media narrative and the
momentum that you get okay that's fair
Iowa you get the headlines you get to
get the victory speech and they denied
Bernie Sanders that even though he won
the popular vote and they let people
Church run around and pretend like he
just won this fair and square
even though he had a he paid forty one
thousand dollars a coupling that
community app and then yeah but little
more with the sedative part that I'm
interested in which is I agree with you
a lot of these early primaries the
number of Delegates is not the most
important thing it's sort of the PR and
being able to claim viability and
victory or whatever
I actually I I don't know yet whether
that's even really happening for Pete
beyond just doing well in New Hampshire
like I still think we need a few more
primaries before we can even say that
that's going on because Amy Klobuchar is
the one who most drastically
overperformed the polls in New Hampshire
you've got in South Carolina
all of a sudden Tom Steyer comes in and
he's polling second in a lot of Super
Tuesday states Bloomberg is doing better
than Budaj edge so I get I'm keeping an
open mind I want to see what happens
yeah I'm not saying that it just because
they did this it's gonna solidify people
to church as the front-runner he's gonna
run away with the Democrat nomination
yeah but I think it's important that we
all recognize what happened this was a
sham election where a candidate had on
the real influence over possibly the the
mechanism you're breaking up again Dante
but again I don't have I don't have
proof that Dante had Dante I don't have
proof that Pete had influence over that
mechanism we know the connections I just
AM unclear that the the diskens the
degree of conspiracy that some are
asserting without proof seems completely
overwrought given the actual impact that
it had but in any case we would
certainly find for us to simply
disagree I do agree generally speaking
with you that the benefit of Iowa repeat
was running around claiming victory not
the extra delegate we agree there and
then just one more point that I want to
make so I think that there should be a
lot of there should be conversation
about what we run in 2016 because even
though it was four years ago it is
incredibly relevant and it's we haven't
really wrapped our minds around the most
of the country that's not authorized
well the fact that in their own word the
DNC was caught breaking their own
Charter violating their own rules and
favoring one candidate over the other
and a primary embrace and I we've talked
about that so so extensively I don't
want to dig back into that we've covered
that for four years so I'm gonna let you
go I've got so many people that want to
get on and always great to hear from you
but we covered that so much as many of
you know I am super careful about where
we publish and distribute David Pakman
show content it's a really important
decision that we make where do we want
our content to be we don't want to
spread ourselves too thin but we want to
make sure that we're taking advantage of
good platforms where our content could
do well and over the last couple of
months I've been testing publishing our
content to a platform called library
that's lbr why I've mentioned it once or
twice before and we are absolutely
loving it it's a fantastic platform
where our revenue as publishers does not
depend on some algorithm deciding
whether an ad should run before a video
or not in fact it's actually an ad-free
platform where our revenue is determined
by the number of people that watch our
videos and also by the tips better left
for us in credits that are in platform
credits it's their own sort of currency
so to speak by viewers like you
and right now for people who sign up on
this platform it's completely free using
the link down in the video description
for every verified signup we get a
little bit of a credit and you also get
a credit of tips that you can then leave
on content that you like such as the
david pakman show content that we
Publishing so use the link down in the
video description no algorithmic
determinations about whether we get to
make money or we don't get to make money
or any of that stuff all of our video
content is being published there use
that link sign up you'll get a credit
will get a credit and it's a beautiful
thing and I'll update you guys in a
couple of weeks about how it's going
there's also a contest that they're
running whoever can refer the most new
users gets a huge reward which would be
a big big boost to us so check it out
link down in the video description sign
up let me know what you think